قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن ان
المجموعه الاستشاريه للدفاع والامن الخاصه
باوكرانيا مصره على دعم كييف في مواجهه
روسيا واضاف اوستن في اجتماعا للمجموعه في
قاعده رمشتاين في المانيا ان الدعم
الامريكي لكيف تجاوز 26 مليار دولار منذ
بدء الهجوم الروسي واوضح ان واشنطن زادت
دعمها لاوكرانيا يشمل منظومه دفاعا جوي من
طراز باتريوت وبطاريه وذخائر مرتبطه بها
فضلا عن العربات المصفحه والمدرعات اضافه
الى التدريب
ووصف اوستن بولندا بانها كانت رائده من
بين الدول الاوروبيه في تقديم الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا وكذلك المانيا وشدد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي على ان روسيا تكبدت
الكثير من الخسائر على الارض كما تنقصها
الذخيره حسب قوله